hallo hallo dies wäre zu früh schon die
halo kategorie
heute gibt's eine torte und zwar mache
ich einen opec torte aus dem kühlschrank
ist wird diesmal eine leckere kost orte
und sie ist auch also ich finde sie sehr
leicht sehr angenehm weil ich keine
schweren krieges mit drin habe sondern
sie besteht aus einem guss verboten mit
kokosflocken und löffel betritt dann ist
dann eine schicht creme obendrauf so
eine art pudding und dann noch eine
kleine schicht sahne und ich würde sagen
wir starten direkt und ich zeige euch
einmal die zutaten setzt euch jetzt den
größten boden her dafür habe hier drei
zutaten der kunde tram löffelbiskuits
100 gramm kokosraspeln und 125 gramm
butter die habe ich bereits verlassen
geht jetzt auch ganz einfach ich nehme
die läufe bestritt und zerkleinerte das
mache ich jetzt in einem x8 ihr könnt
aber zum beispiel auch in gefrierbeutel
nehmen und dann einfach mit einem
ausbaustopp zu überholen und dann habe
ich hier auch schon mal meine form
gerichtet und zwar einen bug rahmen den
nämlich auf 20 zentimeter eingestellt
und einfach backpapier drumherum
geschlagen
da gebe ich jetzt noch die butter mit
dazu und die kokosraspeln möchte ich
später damit die einfach münster
kleinert werden
jetzt fühle ich die masse in den bart
rahmen ein und ihr könnt es besser für
ihn wenn ihr eine größere schale nehmt
aber ich wollte mehr sparen
dann verteile ich die maße schön und
drückt sie dann glatt
denn brüssel boden habe ich es kalt
gestellt und in der zwischenzeit kann
ich jetzt schon mal die füllung zu
bereiten und für die füllung brauche ich
4 eigelb eine prise salz etwas vanille
extrakt 400 milliliter milch 200
milliliter schlagsahne 100 gramm zucker
jetzt kam speisestärke und ich nehm
später für die füllung noch zwei reife
banane und die bananen dürfen wir
richtig reif sein also das ist auch gut
wenn diese frauen flecken außen haben
dann sind nämlich schön süß so jetzt
muss ich die füllung in einem topf zu
bereiten und dafür vermische ich es
einfach alle zutaten darin aber damit
ich keine klümpchen habe zuerst die
stärke
mit ein bisschen milch man kann ich das
nämlich glatt rühren im schneebesen
dann geben sie auch direkt die eigelbe
mit rein zu werden auch glatt gerührt
und durch die eigelbe bekommt die
füllung dann auch die schöne farbe
vor allem wenn ihr halt bio-eier benutzt
es gibt hier einfach noch die restliche
milch nun auch die anderen zutaten mit
rein
und jetzt ruhig die masse so lange und
erhebt es sie auf mittlerer stufe bis
sich so eine art putin gebildet habe
die creme ist schön fest geworden und
lassen jetzt ganz kurz andere seite
stehen und kann schon mal die bananen in
feine scheiben schneiden
die verteidigt jetzt direkt auf dem
kuchen boden
m
jetzt lege ich hier einen siebter über
und streicht den pudding einmal durch so
habe ich dann einfach keine klümpchen
mit dabei und dann verteidigt im pudding
richtig schön glatt über den bananen
jetzt muss der kuchen nochmal gekühlt
werden am besten für mindestens 4
stunden im kühlschrank
ihr könnt ihr aber zum beispiel auch
gerne über nacht drin lassen und dafür
decke gehen jetzt einmal mit einer
zarten platte ab als auch mit so einem
teig retter und machen dann später fällt
die torte ist jetzt abgekühlt und jetzt
kommt noch die letzte schicht drauf das
ist geschlagene sahne
deswegen habe ich jetzt hier 200 gramm
schlagsahne und da gebe ich dann noch
zwei teelöffel sein apartment dazu
mit verstreicht die sahne noch über das
putting green
letzte streich die torte noch mit ein
paar kokosraspeln und mit ein paar kokos
chips
ich hätte die torte jetzt nochmal mit
der fahne im kühlschrank einfach damit
die sahne noch mal schön fest wert wobei
sie auch direkt fest ist aber es war
auch schön kalt wird jetzt schneidig die
torte an
das ist so irritierend weil oben ist
alles weich wie eine wolke und unten
hat man diesen genuss verboten man
schneidet mal durch und dann wird es
plötzlich fest dass ich zumindest sehr
lecker total exotisch tropical so banane
kokosmilch das markieren so lieben hat
richtig schön mit dem gelb und sollte
eigentlich so richtig leicht schmecken
stück dann noch dieser knusperflocken
dieses banane kokos gute kommen eine
gute community
ich finde halt optisch auch schön also
das sieht hier aus wie sollen welt gehen
deswegen ja auch diese habe ich an die
sahne so bisserl wolken mäßig gemacht
und ja ich finde es ist eine leichte
beute vor allem ist eine kühlschrank
torte ohne backen hat was von batida de
coco pina colada ananas mit kokos
sitzung hat plane mit kokos ja also man
hat sich eben noch gewünschten papier
sicher oder mandarinen mit rein will man
natürlich auch austauschen also wenn
jetzt keine bananen volt können
natürlich auch andere früchte oder
anderes obst und rein weiß ich auch
probieren übernahme in mandarin probiert
alles klar an das rezept geht es dann
zum nachlesen auf 6 - blog.de
ich habe selbst nach 20 uhr form
gebacken falls sie das mal umrechnen
volt auf eine größere springform ich
habe eine umrechnung tabelle auf meinem
blog
da müsst ihr dann einfach nur an der
tabelle ablesen von 20 auf zum beispiel
26 und können dann nennt durchmesser
eben auch etwas größeren zug fällt um
rechnungs tabelle 1
genau dann kommt man direkt drauf also
viel spaß zum nachmachen und bis zum
nächsten mal
lasst mich mal probieren
tschüss sanierer schreit ein wunsch ist
aber um aussagen eher schlecht oder
vielleicht ja vielleicht kommt mir vor
nachdem drei toten nicht vergessen haben
also mal auf wiedersehen und jetzt
abschalten